And the order of the letters that you should have is b equals a times c plus d.
However, you could also have a and c switched here. Of course, because of the
commutative property of multiplication. Doesn't matter whether we multiply the
number of nozzles by the cost to make each nozzle or the cost to make each
nozzle by the number of nozzles made. Either way you have it. This equation says
that the total amount that Grant will spend on nozzle production depends both on
how much he spends on the new machinery to allow for that production, and how
much he spends in buying products to make each nozzle. Please notice what we're
looking for the problem in the end is the quantity d over here. The cost of new
machinery to Grant. And although it's not by itself an equation yet, you can use
your algebra skills to pretty easily rearrange things so that d is by itself.